CNN'S RENE MARSH IS COVERING
TODAY'S HEARING IN WASHINGTON.
I GUESS A BIG QUESTION IS, DID
THE PILOTS RELY AS SOME HAVE
SUGGESTED TOO HEAVILY ON
AUTOMATION, THE COMPUTERS THAT
CAN RUN THE PLANE?
>> THAT IS ONE OF THE KEY
QUESTIONS THAT INVESTIGATORS ARE
DIGGING INTO.
AND YOU KNOW, WE JUST GOT SOME
NEW VIDEO COMING OUT OF THAT
HEARING THAT WE WANT TO GET
RIGHT TO.
WE KNOW THAT THAT VIDEO AGAIN,
THIS IS FROM AIRPORT SECURITY
CAMERAS, AND THIS SHOWS US A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE THAT WE
HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE OF THIS
CRASH AS IT HAPPENED.
THAT IS THE VIDEO THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THERE.
SOME INCREDIBLE DETAILS COMING
OUT OF THIS HEARING.
THE NTSB SAYS THAT THE PILOT
FLYING THE PLANE WAS CONCERNED
PRIOR TO THE CRASH.
HE TOLD INVESTIGATORS THAT HE
FOUND A VISUAL APPROACH
DIFFICULT AND STRESSFUL.
WE SHOULD MENTION HE WAS TASKED
WITH MAKING A VISUAL APPROACH AS
HE WAS GOING TO SAN FRANCISCO'S
AIRPORT.
NOW, WHEN ASKED HOW CONFIDENT HE
WAS ABOUT HIS KNOWLEDGE OF THE
TRIPLE 7s AUTOMATED FLIGHT
SYSTEMS, I'M QUOTING FROM THE
TRANSCRIPT, HE SAID, HE'S NOT SO
CONFIDENT.
HE FELT THAT HE SHOULD STUDY
MORE.
AGAIN, THAT COMING FROM THE
PILOT WHO WAS AT THE CONTROLS
SAYING HE WASN'T VERY CONFIDENT
WITH THE AUTOMATED SYSTEMS
INSIDE THAT PLANE.
NTSB INVESTIGATORS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT PILOTS OVERRELIANCE ON
AUTOMATED SYSTEMS IN THE
COCKPIT.
SPECIFICALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE PLANE'S AUTO THROTTLE.
IT'S THE EQUIVALENT OF CRUISE
CONTROL IN A CAR, AND THE PILOT
THOUGHT THAT THE AUTO THROTTLE
WAS ENGAGED, BUT IT TURNED OUT
IT WAS NOT.
THAT US CAED THE PLANE TO FALL
TO A DANGEROUSLY SLOW SPEED.
IT SUGGESTS A FEW THINGS.
THE PILOT DIDN'T RECOGNIZE THAT
THE AUTO THROTTLE WAS
DISENGAGED.
THEY WEREN'T CROSS-CHECKING
POSSIBLY THE EQUIPMENT OR AGAIN,
THEY DIDN'T FULLY UNDERSTAND HOW
TO OPERATE THE PLANE'S AUTOMATED
SYSTEMS.
ANYWAY WAY YOU LOOK AT IT, T